What's so much of what happens in
schools,
it's about somehow not trying to
transgress on the interest of adults.
So,
uh,
from a symbolic perspective,
in order to ensure that everybody knew
that,
that everybody has skin in the game,
uh,
because,
many of the,
many of the schools that we chose to
close had been really toxic environments
in terms of,
of their outcomes for kids over time.
Uh,
because,
uh,
it seemed to us that if we were going to
create settings that we're going to work
for kids,
uh,
in a transformational way over time.
We needed to,
we needed to give people a chance in a,
in,
in terms of starting new new communities
and settings that,
that,
uh,
had truly different cultures.
Uh,
we chose to close schools.
it's,
it's unexplored in early hard endeavor
because one of the things that,
uh,
that,
every superintendent who tries this,
uh,
immediately learns is that it doesn't
matter how bad our school is.
Uh,
the community doesn't want to close.
you have schools where,
you know,
25% of the kids are performing a
proficient and events or were,
you know,
30% of the kids have,
have graduated.
And you have people coming to tell you
that,
that now,
no,
it's not.
It's not about the schools,
it's about the school not getting
support.
Uh,
there's also a sense in neighborhoods,
schools are very much part of the
history of neighborhoods.
And,
uh,
anybody who there's two closest school
in some way is,
is,
is violating,
uh,
a story arc for that neighborhood.
Uh,
people,
uh,
graduated from that school.
Uh,
uh,
quite often you have teachers who,
who attended the school.
Uh,
and there's always this,
this the sense that that the central
office has not done its job.
Uh,
which for us was,
was,
uh,
you know,
something that we,
we,
we admitted from the stars and this is
not about the schools per se.
This is about how a system has accepted
failure of a time.
And if we're,
if we're going to succeed,
then we need to understand that a,
that there has to be a process of
renewal.
And a,
and we need to give a new schools a
chance.
Uh,
so it wasn't hard for us,
uh,
in terms of making the decision.
It was hard to implement it.
Uh,
we closed a six last year.
we're closing another five this year.
We just announced it on Tuesday.
Uh,
we'd already launched in that process
of,
of having conversations with community
that,
uh,
takes tremendous energy from staff.
Uh,
and,
uh,
you know,
we,
it does by the way,
that there's this debate about whether
the way to improve school systems is to
close schools to turn him around.
I mean,
I think it takes everything.
Uh,
we closed some,
we turned some around in terms of,
of,
of bringing in new programs.
Uh,
but,
but the closure,
uh,
of the worst performing schools,
I think it's,
it's absolutely necessary,
uh,
as long as we're providing something
that is better,
uh,
as part of the exchange.
So,
uh,
it's been a hard thing for us to do,
but something that I think is making the
district,
uh,
much better.
We've become predictable,
which is,
which is a really good thing in terms of
how,
how organizations work.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
principals understand that if,
if,
if the outcomes go down,
uh,
there are certain consequences and the
consequences are not simply about the
kids.
Uh,
it's about what happens to,
to an institution right now.
For example,
I'm recommending the non renewal of a
charter.
Uh,
it will be the first time thought I
chatted is none renewed in,
uh,
in the district.
And the reason for that is that,
you know,
here's a school that has all the
autonomy in the world.
The district is advancing,
the school is regressing.
Well,
you know,
uh,
the school loses the charter,
in the same way that a traditional
school might be close.